der weltraum unendliche weiten und jetzt
auch mit einem neuen besitzer den
vereinigten staaten von amerika was
experten zu den besitzverhältnissen des
alls sagen und was anschauen seit 1967
bestehende vertrag darüber aussagt dass
jetzt bei pixum science fiction
am 25 november unterzeichnete der
amerikanische präsident barack obama ein
dokument das die bisherigen verhältnisse
im weltall quasi auf den kopf stellt mit
der unterschrift tritt der us commercial
space launch kompetitives act in kraft
damit haben sich die usa das
verwaltungsrecht des gesamten welt als
gesichert dadurch soll beispielsweise
das amerikanische verkehrsministerium
jeden privat kommerziellen weltraumflug
verwalten
laut den amerikanern ist die sicherheit
im all besonders wichtig und dafür soll
das us-verteidigungsministerium sorgen
bei der ausbeutung von rohstoffen auf
asteroiden oder anderen planeten braucht
man zunächst einmal die genehmigung der
nasa im dokument steht das übersetzt so
jedwedes von einem asteroiden im all
gewonnene material ist besitz der
körperschaft die das material gewonnen
hat die damit alle besitzrechte gewinnt
im einklang mit dem us bundesrecht und
existenten internationalen
verpflichtungen zitat ende
wie aber kamen die amerikaner gerade
jetzt darauf solche besitzrechte zu
beanspruchen und dürfen sie das
überhaupt gedanken über die
besitzverhältnisse hat man sich schon
sehr sehr viel früher gemacht genauer
gesagt im jahr 1967
damals setzten sich die vereinten
nationen an einen tisch und beschlossen
gemeinsam den vertrag über die
grundsätze zur regelung der tätigkeiten
von staaten bei der erforschung und
nutzung des weltraums einschließlich des
mondes und anderer himmelskörper
unterschrieben haben diesen vertrag
unter anderem russland aber auch die usa
im jahr 1967 war der wettlauf um die
eroberung des weltraums zwischen
russland und den usa schon lange
entbrannt einige jahre im jahr 1961
zuvor hatte russland juri gagarin und
damit den ersten menschen ins weltall
geschossen
us präsident john f kennedy erteilte im
selben jahr der nasa die aufgabe bis zum
ende des jahrzehnts einen menschen zum
mond zu schicken was später 1969 dann
auch gelang
daher war es an der zeit für klare
regeln zur möglichen besitzansprüchen ja
aufzustellen
der weltraum vertrag von 1967 schloss
und das steht jetzt im gegensatz zum
neuen us gesetz die nationale anleitung
durch beanspruchen der hoheitsgewalt
durch benutzung oder okkupation oder
durch andere mittel aus in dem vertrag
von 167 wurde neben den eben genannten
grundsätzen ein weiterer sehr sehr
wichtiger punkt geklärt im all dürfen
keinerlei nukleare stützpunkte errichtet
werden
atomraketen oder ähnliches sind also da
oben verboten
der vertrag und da sagt auch dass es nur
ein einziges verwaltungsorgan für den
weltraum gibt mit dem neuen vertrag
ändern die usa also die spielregeln
neben der nasa gibt es natürlich noch
andere weltraumorganisationen wie die
esa zum beispiel oder die russische
raumfahrtbehörde roskosmos aber von
keiner keiner gab es bisher ein
statement zu amerikas plänen russland
wird sich das aber wohl eher nicht
gefallen lassen
mit rechten ergeben sich natürlich auch
pflicht nehmen wir also mal an die usa
würden das weltall bekommen welche
pflichten sind eigentlich mit dem besitz
des weltalls verbunden im mai diesen
jahres kamen in köln zahlreiche experten
zu der tagung wem gehört der mond
zusammen bernhard schmidt ted vom dlr
dem deutschen zentrum für luft und
raumfahrt sprach dort ein paar
verantwortungsbereiche an er sprach zum
beispiel die problematik an dass es dort
oben schon recht voll ist sie tat es
muss auch geklärt werden ob ein aktiver
satellit einem abgeschalteten satelliten
vorsorglich ausweichen muss und wer dann
den rg energieverbrauch dafür bezahlt
zitat ende
während also die usa als selbst ernannte
oberste weltraum instanzen dafür
verantwortlich und weil so viele objekte
im weltraum sind hat sich dort über die
letzten jahrzehnte einiges an
weltraumschrott angesammelt hier auf
diesem bild sieht man es da ist schon
eine ganze menge wer soll das also alles
entsorgen wäre das jetzt auch ein job
für die usa ein ganz wichtiger punkt
sind die schürfrechte im all
denn so manchem himmelskörper befinden
sich seltene elemente die man vielleicht
schon bald effektiv ausbeuten kann
der weltraum ist also von großem
wirtschaftlichen interesse die usa haben
wie früher im goldrausch also gerade den
größten claim aller zeiten ab
deckt zwar wollen die vereinigten
staaten mit ihrem neuen gesetz nur
verwalten allerdings bleibt abzuwarten
wie andere staaten reagieren wenn die
erstmal angefangen haben rohstoffe auf
asteroiden abzubauen
lasst uns darüber mal in den kommentaren
diskutieren was sagt ihr dazu
ist das jetzt ein imperialistischer akt
der usa haben die usa in anspruch darauf
den weltraum zu regulieren
ja und wie könnte man ansonsten mit den
rohstoffen verfahren ich bin auf eure
meinung gespannt und ansonsten ja und
abo nicht vergessen ist er kostenlos
video in das nächste video schauen und
bis dann bleibt dran